hey what is up everybody it's animak
here for
anime empror and today i will be talking
about the latest crazy twist
in the boku no hero story a twist that
changes absolutely everything we thought
we knew
about where the story is heading next
deku just made a decision that i
personally wasn't expecting
and this is a decision that will have
massive consequences
on the world of boku no hero this really
is
earth shattering stuff so let's get into
it
if you enjoyed the boku no hero content
here on the channel and you want us to
keep it going please leave a like to let
me know
it really does help and if you are new
to anime out pro
or maybe you watch our videos but you
haven't taken the time to subscribe yet
make this the video that you subscribe
and hit that notification bell to turn
on
all notifications a quick shout out to
my
editor dakota broski i really feel bad
for him he loves the school arcs in boku
no hero like the festival arcs and the
tournament
and he was really hoping that after this
war arc
things would go back to normal over at
ua
as i thought that is definitely not
going to happen dakota is going to be
heartbroken so please show him some love
and check out his anime channel
link in the description
[Music]
finally this video will of course
contain boku no hero manga spoilers so
please proceed with caution
you have been warned the latest chapter
begins with all might who is still by
deku's side
at the hospital all might can feel the
emotions
coursing through deku as he speaks to
the previous users of one for all
although he doesn't know exactly what's
being said all might can tell that deku
is undergoing some kind of
test and all might also has the feeling
that being quirkless
ended up being a blessing rather than a
curse for him
and deku this is something that we had
learned a few chapters ago
now that it has become so powerful one
for all will burn out
the bodies of its users if those users
were born with a quirk
and unfortunately those users will end
up dying way before their time
but inheritors of one for all who were
born quirkless
are safe at least as far as we know and
of course you guys know what this means
since the new chapter starts off with
all might in the real world
that means that horikoshi is going to
continue teasing us about the identity
of the second
and third users oh man we can assume
that deku has met them by now
but we the readers have not so we still
don't know why their identity has been
so deliberately hidden up to this point
in the story i really wanted to learn
more about those guys
in this chapter definitely let me know
what you guys think about them down in
the comments
who were they and why do they keep
hiding their identities
all might who is very emotional at this
point and he even wipes away a tear
is then visited by hawks and best genius
the two of them are still trying to
figure out what is going on with one for
all
because they need to prepare a proper
response for the public
hawks explains that the existence of one
for all was revealed during the battle
of jakku
and the media has picked up on it the
news is now spreading rapidly and on top
of that
endeavour told hawks that shigaraki was
going after
deku even though we as the readers know
the truth about one for all
we have to recognize that all of this
sounds extremely strange to someone like
hawks
why would an overpowered villain like
shigaraki who can take out entire cities
be going after a 16 year old high school
student like
deku hawks and genius can tell that they
are missing something here
something big and important but they
don't know what
hawks says that they are no longer just
fighting the villains
society as a whole is outraged that the
heroes failed to stop the villains from
causing mass
carnage across japan and after all of
those revelations about
endeavor the public no longer trusts the
heroes
the media is out for blood regular
everyday people
are out for blood and of course all
those villains and escaped convicts are
also
out for blood this is an extremely
dangerous and sensitive situation for
the pro heroes so they need to handle it
as soon as possible
all might tells hawks and genus that
this isn't the place to talk about
something like this but he vows to tell
them everything when the time
is right we then see principal nezu
receiving a call
in which he confirms that he will send a
request for government assistance
presumably for the ua itself three days
have passed since all for one's
insane prison break but the panic hasn't
stopped
the streets of japan still look like a
war zone as the villains continue to
rampage and as the regular citizens
continue to take justice into their own
hands
and not only is the situation not
getting any better but it is actively
getting worse
as the panic spreads like an infection
eventually the top three pro heroes
which are endeavor hawks and genius
are forced to attend a press conference
and field some very aggressive questions
from reporters
we actually get to see best genius out
of his hero costume and man
his neck is freaking long that extended
turtleneck that he always wears really
hides how long
this man's neck is anyway the reporters
and the general public are demanding
assurances from the heroes
they want assurances that the heroes
will protect everyone and that the
people will be
safe but in this chaotic situation
the heroes simply cannot guarantee
anything and that is exactly the problem
that's why there is this huge
panic everyone is terrified and they
don't trust that the heroes can do
anything to help them
and fear makes people do crazy things
endeavour eventually admits in front of
the reporters that everything dobby said
about him was true
hawks also admits that his father had a
dark criminal
past that he had kept hidden and he
admits to killing the villain
known as twice hawks says that because
of the nature of twice's quirk
if he had just let him escape twice
would have caused far more harm to
society as a whole
he killed twice for the greater good
because
this particular villain was too
dangerous to be left
alive now of course i can see where
hawks is coming from but at the same
time straight up executing someone who
hasn't even had a chance to stand trial
is never a good thing sure heroes might
sometimes be
forced to make such a difficult choice
but it is always a complicated and
highly controversial thing to do
hawks says that he is deeply sorry for
everything that happened and he
apologizes profoundly
as do the other two but that's simply
not enough
for a lot of people including some of
the reporters
many of them had personal connections
with the victims of the villain rampage
and they cannot understand how the
heroes could have made such horrible
mistakes
mistakes that cost so many lives and
that led to so much destruction
saying sorry and admitting you screwed
up won't undo the damage that was done
endeavour knows that the only way to
make up for what he's done and for
what's happened
is to defeat the villains and that is
exactly what he intends to do
we've definitely seen a major shift in
endeavor within just a few
chapters a few chapters ago he was
sobbing uncontrollably and he was a
completely
broken man and yet now he is here
finally taking full responsibility for
his mistakes and vowing to defeat
the villains this is a truly impressive
turnaround
and i'm sure that his family and the
talk that he had with his family had
everything to do with it endeavour is
still injured and his reputation
is in tatters but he is still willing to
fight and this time he didn't shy away
from taking responsibility for his past
best genius then announces that the
protection of certain civilians is going
to be prioritized from now on
and that includes the family members of
the ua hero
students the ua high school itself is
going to serve as a sanctuary for the
students and everyone connected to them
so i assume that the families of the
students are going to be moving
into the ua dormitories along with the
students
this decision was made because the ua
already has top tier security
and it is big enough to accommodate all
of the family members
so it makes sense from a practical
standpoint we even see deku's and
bakugou's moms
already beginning the moving process
okay first of all that's crazy but
second of all
any chapter that features best girl
mitsuki bakugo is a great chapter in my
book
i know we only see like one little image
of her but still mama bakugo
is a queen and as crazy as this whole
thing sounds with all the families of ua
students moving in with them
and setting up an endless amount of
hilariously awkward situations
this was probably not the best time to
announce something like this
i mean the general public is already mad
at the heroes for failing to protect
them from the villains
and then genus is like oh yeah by the
way some civilians are going to receive
preferential treatment because they are
related to the hero
students it's definitely not a bad plan
because the villains really might target
family members of the students
if they get the chance but i don't know
maybe just do it without
announcing it publicly since you know
telling all of japan about your new
security protocol
might be just a bit unwise but that's
just my two cents
endeavour then steps up to the plate
once again and he asks the media to
direct
all of their worries and hatred directly
at him
they don't need to worry about what the
other heroes are doing because as the
number one pro hero
he will take responsibility for
everything again
this is such a huge change for endeavor
for so many years he never even publicly
acknowledged what happened to dobby
or what he did to shoto and the rest of
his family
he was enjoying all the benefits of
being a top tier pro hero
without ever facing up to his past but
now he's done a complete 180.
he admitted everything publicly he took
responsibility for everything
and he vowed to make things right by
taking down the villains
this is impressive character progression
in my opinion
but now we'll have to wait and see if
endeavour can actually live up to his
words
when it really counts since so many
heroes have abandoned their posts
in the face of these unprecedented
challenges those heroes who stayed will
have to work harder than ever and they
will have to be braver than
ever before endeavour then proceeds to
deny any knowledge of one for all in
front of the reporters
and we see a brief glimpse of dobby
reveling in his father's predicament
the chapter then shifts focus to ua
which is obviously undergoing some major
changes
but then another major change is
suddenly forced upon the students
deku has woken up at some point and he
has sent personal letters to his friends
in the letters deku thanks them for
everything and then he proceeds to
straight up tell the truth
about one for all so deku reveals that
he inherited his quirk from
all might and he also reveals that
possessing this quirk makes him a target
for shigaraki
and all for one because of course their
ultimate goal is to somehow steal
one for all because deku is being
directly
targeted by the villains his presence at
ua
is gonna put all of his friends and
classmates in danger and
deku just can't keep doing that so he
decides to leave
the ua wait what the very last page of
the chapter
shows a very cold and stoic looking deku
standing on top of a building
in what appears to be a direct tribute
to jim lee's
batman comic book it is already april by
this point and deku looks
on as a big villain attacks the city he
appears to be wearing gran torino's cape
or at least what's left of it after the
battle of jakku and it's not just a cape
that's new this appears to be a whole
new
deku i mean just compare his expression
here in chapter 306
to his excitement back in chapter 1 when
he also saw a giant villain
attacking the city that old deku who was
ironically the younger deku
was just a hero fanboy and he was
excited to see
some hero versus villain action this
deku
understands the crushing responsibility
of being a hero
this deku understands that the actions
of villains have
terrible consequences and this deku is
far more mature and far darker than the
deku that we met
back in chapter 1 of the story those of
you who have been following this channel
for a while
know that i've been saying for a very
long time that the war arc
is going to change everything including
deku i
said that things will never be the same
again because the hero society will
change forever and deku himself will
change forever
after he realizes the full extent of the
damage that was done
and the lives that were lost after the
war arc
we are not just going to go back to
school festival arcs and fun little
tournament arcs
and business as usual sorry dakota the
world has changed and
deku has changed with it but to be
perfectly honest even i wasn't expecting
deku to straight up leave
the ua if he doesn't finish his hero
education
he cannot become a full-fledged hero i
understand where he's coming from and i
know that he's just trying to protect
his friends
but what does this mean isn't this
supposed to be the story of how
deku became the greatest hero is deku
about to give up on being a hero
and become a vigilante instead and that
would explain the batman reference
because batman
is a vigilante or is deku going to come
back to ua once
this villain threat is finally
eliminated and if so
who knows how long that might actually
take
are we about to see a major time skip in
the boku no hero story
definitely let me know what you guys
think about this crazy twist
down in the comments below what will
deku do now
and how will his decision affect the
rest of the story
also what did you think about
endeavour's behavior
in this chapter do you feel that he is
finally beginning to take
full responsibility for his actions and
that he is finally beginning to make
amends for his mistakes
or are you still skeptical about him
finally
how good was this chapter it had some
amazing character development amazing
world development
and then that deku twist at the end
absolutely
top tier chapter in my opinion do you
guys agree
let me know down below if you enjoyed
this video and you want to see more boku
no hero content right here on the
channel
please leave a like to let me know it
really does help
and if you are new to anime pro or maybe
you watch our videos but you haven't
subscribed yet
make this the video that you subscribe
and hit that notification bell to turn
on
all notifications you really have to go
through the trouble of subscribing
hitting that bell and then selecting the
option that says all
it's annoying but if you don't do all of
those things you're still gonna miss a
ton of our videos even if you are
subscribed
it's just how youtube works you can also
hit me up on twitter
and instagram at anime uproar
a big thank you to all of our anime
outpour patrons for making videos like
this one possible
special thank you to alpha sigma
disciple
of lord twego himself and i can't forget
our
the one tier patrons the ones who stand
above
all other clans including ingrata
acquired respect
pate heffa liam thompson algertal dr
cortman dustin scarlett emperor otaku
spidey life chanel baked buddhist
tungsten tarcus
and yuno finally thank you also to our
pro hero tier patrons
including the one and only gilgamesh
steelers angel cruz anatoly kazatsky
cricket xp wrathween deora very gucci
alicia octor
bonnie parks hinokamian water joanne
garcia the red-haired raven
ted no ted isparky65 fatboy games deadly
saint and soul race slice and dice
if you enjoy our videos and you feel
that they provide value to you consider
supporting us
on patreon even a single dollar will
give you access to our patron exclusive
discord
and your name will appear in our videos
along with these legendary people
as always thank you guys so much for
watching and until next time see ya
space cowboys
[Music]
you